[Music]
The past holds within it a trove of stories
that continue to shape the present and future
one such story is out of Andrew Jackson the
seventh president of the United States who
fatally wounded a man during a duel in the
early 1800s and instead of getting condemned
and thrown in jail for it he received praise
and recognition that helped him attain the
highest political position in the country in a
time where personal honor was a prized virtue
Mr Jackson took the risk of taking another
man's life for the sake of his reputation
Jackson's opponent was a man named Charles
Dickinson, a hot-headed and quarrelsome
lawyer residing in the state of Tennessee he was
known for being a skilled Marksman and a duelist
and was involved in at least 26 duels during
his lifetime the animosity between Jackson and
Dickinson had been building for years fueled by
insults, accusations and even a horse race that
ended in controversy one of the first disputes
happened in 1803 when Jackson served as a judge
in a case involving a debt owed by Dickinson to
a man named George Eliot Dickinson had borrowed
money from Elliot and had not paid it back and
Elliot sued him to recover it as the judge in
the matter Jackson ruled in favor of Elliot
Dickinson was enraged by this decision however
and challenged Jackson to a duel in response
Jackson accepted the challenge but the two men
were prevented from fighting at the time due to
the intervention of local authorities the incident
only served to increase the tension between the
two men and set the stage for later confrontations
in 1805 at a horse race in Nashville Tennessee
Jackson entered his prized Thoroughbred into
the race and bet a significant amount of money on
him to win Dickinson who was known for his skills
as a horseman and gambler also entered a horse to
compete during the race their horses were neck and
neck with Jackson shouting encouragement to his
horse as they approached the Finish Line in the
end Jackson's Thoroughbred won by a slim margin
According to some witnesses Dickinson was enraged
by this outcome and accused Jackson of cheating,
claiming that by wearing weighted stirrups,
Jackson's horse had an unfair Advantage the
argument between the two men became heated,
and at one point, Dickinson insulted Jackson's
wife Rachel later that same year, Dickinson
published a letter in a local newspaper accusing
Jackson of cheating and of having a violent temper
he also again made insulting remarks about
Jackson's wife Rachel finally the line had
been crossed with Jackson, and he officially
challenged his rival to a duel to defend his honor
and thus, on May 30th 1806, the two men met
on the banks of the Red River in Logan County
Kentucky the exact number of people who attended
the duel is not known, but it's estimated that
between 30 and 100 people may have been present to
witness the event that day according to witnesses,
the weather was hot and humid with the sun
beating down on the two men as they stood
facing each other the atmosphere surrounding
the duel was tense and charged with emotion
both men were known for their fiery personalities
and quick tempers, and the insults and accusations
that had led to the challenge had only served to
intensify the animosity between them despite the
gravity of the situation, the rules of the duel
were followed with strict adherence to protocol
and these rules were simple, 24 feet apart,
each man with the pistol and the first to
hit his opponent would be declared the winner
after each man's assistants, called seconds,
carefully measured out the distance between the
two combatants, the two men stood silently glaring
at each other in the Kentucky sunlight and the
duel began Jackson took aim, but hesitated before
firing Dickinson, however, did not hesitate and
fired his shot, hitting Jackson in the chest
and fracturing his arm Jackson Managed to cover
the wound with his hand to contain the bleeding,
and while remaining calm and upright, he aimed
and fired, striking Dickinson in the chest and
fatally wounding him while Dickinson's assistants
contended that Jackson's first shot had misfired,
which would have signaled the end of The
Duel, Jackson had disregarded this tradition
by resetting his gun and firing again, ultimately
causing Dickinson's fatality though Jackson would
eventually recover from his own wound, the injury
left him with persistent discomfort throughout the
remainder of his life not long afterward Jackson
was charged with murder by the authorities in
Kentucky but he was eventually acquitted the
incident caused a great deal of controversy and
was heavily criticized by some who viewed dueling
as barbaric and archaic despite the criticism,
Jackson's reputation as a man of honor and
integrity only grew following the event
he would go on to serve in numerous political
positions afterward, even as the seventh president
of the United States and so the famous duel
between Andrew Jackson and Charles Dickinson
was cemented in history a tragic event
that highlights the importance placed on
personal honor and reputation in the past while
dueling may seem barbaric and unnecessary today,
it was a commonly accepted practice in the
19th century Jackson's methods in the duel
helped to solidify his reputation as a man of
great integrity and courage, a reputation that
would follow him throughout his life and career
The Duel can also be seen as a pivotal moment
in American history, a dramatic clash between
two formidable men that spoke to the tensions
and rivalries of the era while the outcome of
the duel is a matter of record, with Jackson
emerging Victorious but badly wounded, the deeper
significance of the event lies in what it revealed
about the character of the men involved and the
broader societal forces that shaped their lives
for Jackson The Duel was a test of his honor and
reputation, a chance to defend his wife's honor
and establish himself as a man of courage and
conviction for Dickinson, it was an opportunity
to prove his own mettle and assert his dominance
over a rival yet in the end, both men were
changed by the experience and the legacy of their
conflict would resonate for generations to come
thank you
[Music]